So you guys are now in the front.
You guys want to Yeah. mute yourselves?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. If your sister can talk as well if
she has questions. I know she's here.
>> Yeah. Jessica, you got any questions
that you were wondering?
>> Your your mic is muted, Jessica. So you
can unmute it so you can speak. Let me
see.
You'd have to do it on your part. I
can't do it for you.
>> What's up, Danny Yonan? What's up,
buddy? Power. This guy is like Mr.
Olympia. I'm starting to hate you,
brother, because I got love handles.
Yeah. So, she I don't know if she knows
how to unmute herself because she's not
a mute.
Help her out.
Speak clearly in mic, brother, because I
think your mic's terrible, too.
Jessica, you're okay.
>> Now you're unmuted. Good.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah.
>> Good, good, good. What about you, Ed?
Can you speak to the mic?
We lost your brother now. It's amazing,
huh? This called spiritual war.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, you know, I was born
as a Christian, so
>> I mean, I know
>> I know pretty much a lot about
Christianity and like I told my brother,
I made my own decision becoming Muslim.
For me, that's the right path. I did my
research. I'm not going to say I fully
know and understand, but I am, you know,
I'm learning as I go.
>> Well, I don't know if you know
Christianity. I have to ask you
questions to see that. So, you said you
did a lot of research into Islam and
Christianity. I mean, I can ask you
10,000 questions, especially about
Tohed. If you really know about Tohed
and all that, I don't know, but we'll
see. Turn off your camera at so they
don't see you. Turn off your camera so I
can bring you up.
>> Do you want them to see you? Okay. All
right. So, when you Okay. All right.
Study Christianity. So if I were to ask
you,
if you studied the New Testament and you
studied the words of Jesus Christ,
>> have you seen where Jesus made himself
out to be God but not the father?
>> That's the part that I told my brother
that I'm very confused.
>> Okay.
>> Because um yeah, in Christianity I was
born, like I said, I was born and
raised. I got baptized and I um they
taught me no Christianity. They taught
me that Jesus is God. Okay. But you know
once I went into Islam and I did my
research and it's to me it didn't became
possible for a human to be God. Like I
always tell my brother in the 10 in the
>> possible for God to become human.
Jessica so you know what God can and
cannot do. What does the Quran say? God
can't become man. Can you give me the
ayah in the surah?
Uh, I don't have it on top of my head,
but I know I have it written down
somewhere.
>> But remember my question. You said it's
impossible. Unless God told you that in
Revelation, we don't speak for God. So,
I want to know where the Quran says God
cannot become a man without ceasing to
be God. Because according to your own
tradition, your God appeared as a youth
to your prophet, beardless youth with
curly hair. So, how come your God can
appear as a beardless youth with curly
hair?
See, that's another thing. People say
that um you know, he was cur he had
curly hair. He had blue eyes. The Bible
doesn't describe that.
>> Jessica, I didn't say Jesus. I said your
prophet said your god Allah.
>> Your God Allah appeared as a beardless
youth with curly hair. I didn't say
Jesus.
>> Okay. So, here's another thing. That's
what I don't get. You guys as um
Christians always always saying you're
God, Allah. Do you know what Allah
means?
>> You want translate the Arabic to this um
English?
>> You want to ask me when I speak uh
Assyrian?
>> I want to ask you, do you know what
Allah means in Allah? Do you know what
these terms mean?
>> Uh I know that Allah in English, if we
translate it, it's God. Yeah.
>> No, that's not what it means. Allah
comes from
>> What does it mean?
>> Allah comes from two words. El
L means the and in time it became
contracted
and that's where you get Allah. But just
because you use the word Allah that
doesn't mean you have the same God I do.
For example, I'm going to give you an
example in English. If I'm in a room and
there's Hindus and Buddhists and there
are Jews who don't believe in Jesus and
Muslims and Christians and I say praise
God, everyone will say amen. But if I
say praise God, father, son, holy
spirit, only the Christians will amen
me. So just because we may use the same
term doesn't mean we have the same God
in mind. For example, is Jesus your
Allah?
>> No, he's a prophet.
>> We don't have the same God.
>> That that's what exactly that's what I'm
saying.
>> Allah is is God. It's not in Islam.
Jesus is not God.
>> No. I found the the surah that you're
asking me to be surah 4211.
>> No, 4211 does not say what you think. It
says there's nothing comparable to
Allah. I know in 12 that where you were
asking me.
>> No, I didn't ask you that. I said where
does it say Allah cannot become a man?
All you showed me is there's nothing
comparable to Allah. But it doesn't say
Allah cannot become a man without
ceasing to be God. I know what you're
quoting. Chapter 42:1. I'll give you one
to help you.
Chapter 112:4
doesn't say what you said. So can you
show me where it says that Allah cannot
become man without ceasing to be God.
But before we go there Jesus says your
God, the God of the Quran is not the
true God. Because the the God that Jesus
spoke of is not your God. Meaning the
God of the Quran.
So, I don't know how you became a Muslim
when you're a Christian because Jesus
teaching shows that the Quran is not
from the God that sent him as a son and
that according to the New Testament,
Muhammad is Antichrist.
>> How is he antichrist? If in the in the
Quran, he says we have to respect Jesus.
If like you said, you're Syrian, right?
So, you I'm pretty sure you know about
Islam because you know in Syria there's
a lot of Arabic. So, tell me if I'm
lying. If you do not accept Jesus, you
don't respect Jesus and Islam, you
cannot be a Muslim. Is that true or not?
>> That you have the right Jesus because
our New Testament tells us that Satan
will inspire people to talk about Jesus,
but it's not the real Jesus. It's a fake
Jesus. So, you said you read the New
Testament. So, I'm assuming you read 2
Corinthians 11 where we're told that
people who come and preach a Jesus other
than the Jesus preached by his followers
and present a different spirit and a
different gospel. Don't put up with it
because that Satan because Satan appears
as an angel of light. So, your Jesus is
not my Jesus. I know the Quran claims
Isaiam
is Jesus but it's not the real Jesus
because everyone claims to have Jesus.
For example, the Mormons say they
believe in Jesus, but their Jesus is
Yahweh,
who was sired by Elohim the Father,
and he has a wife. Is that your Jesus?
>> No.
>> The Jehovah's Witnesses say Jesus is the
Archangel Michael, the first creature of
God. Is that your Jesus?
>> Nope. So you just admit to me just
because you claim you have a Jesus
doesn't mean we have the same Jesus. So
this again I'm baffled. You said you
came in here you said I'm going by your
words. I've studied Christianity and I
know Christianity. So far from what I'm
gathering you didn't study Christianity
deep enough because had you studied
Christianity deep enough you would know
according to the Christianity you
studied Muhammad is an antichrist. He's
one of those antichrist that Jesus
warned would come to deceive people.
But you know, I do apologize. I have to
cut it short because I do have to go
pray mag.
>> Okay. Come back.
>> Okay.
>> Come back. Wait for you.
>> Okay. Not going anywhere.
>> All right. Bye.
>> All right. Come back.
>> Okay. So,
do we have to Okay. Anyway, so tell
people background about your sister.
>> Well, um, we're pretty much all all of
us born and raised in Christianity.
>> What Christianity? She said she was
baptized.
>> Uh we What do you mean Christianity?
Like uh
>> Do you know there's a lot of
denominations of Christianity, right?
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know
what you mean. Oh, it's so evangelist.
Evangelist.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, so you're evangelical. So, I see.
>> So, we were pretty much brought up in
it, but of course the older of us we got
the mic and louder.
>> Oh, yeah. The the closer, you know, the
older we got, um we just lost our way.
we lose faith, you know, then going to
school kind of
um going to school kind of really messes
it up too, you know. They they brainwash
you with telling you that we live we
came out of a monkey and then
>> I would remember bringing up the Bible
and everything. I mean, no matter what,
we all kind of lost ourselves. The only
one that stayed was my little sister.
She was the only one that stayed in
God's path. And thank God I came back to
it and now I'm seeing my sister when she
finally told me she was Muslim. I had no
idea nothing about Musl I've heard of
them, but I had no idea what they
believed in. But when she was telling me
about it,
>> I was like, "That sounds like kind of
like my belief, but you don't believe in
Jesus." You know,
>> now by the way,
>> she younger than you, the sister of
yours.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Is she younger than you? The sister that
we're speaking to?
>> Oh, no. She's the older one. The younger
one is uh uh the other one. I'm in the
middle.
>> Okay. People don't know that the one of
the reasons why she became Muslim, she
married a Muslim.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. She married a Muslim
and she pretty much
>> Yeah. I I think she just following it.
But then when I ask him questions like
why, she can't answer them. And that's
where I get it. And I'm like, okay, so
why are we following why are you
following a religion that you don't know
what's the point of it?
>> Yeah.
So that's why I was trying to break in
her head like look I I try to explain it
to you. I try to give you videos and and
send you little shorts but you don't
seem to understand it. So I was saying
you know what maybe you can talk to
someone directly ask your questions and
if you got anything error you go ahead
and and ask
>> her questions when she comes up if you
know her questions and ask for her if
she doesn't remember what they are. But
just make sure your sound is good
because I can hear myself through your
>> speaker. Let me get my um
cuz I don't I should put on the
earphones.
So, yeah. So, what was her questions
that she asked you so far?
>> She's muted, guys. One second.
Hopefully. Pray if she comes back. I
don't want her to leave.
>> Yeah. I'm trying to see if I can connect
some earphones.
>> No, you're all right now. Good. So, what
was the question she asked?
>> Well, one of her questions is um how do
you uh give me a second?
>> I tried to explain to her that it's
>> What was her question?
>> I tried to explain to her that uh it's
Oh, her question was she asked how can
Christians believe in two gods? I
thought that one god question.
>> Okay. When she asked me that question,
let her come up ask me that question. I
want to see. Okay. So that was one
question question.
>> What was the other question?
>> Okay. Um well the other question I know
for a fact is she keeps saying why
Christianity? Why can it not be Muslims
if we follow?
>> Why should it be Islam? I don't get it.
Why? Okay. If that's that logic, why not
Mormonism? Because Jesus is alive. He's
risen. Muhammad is dead. But hopefully
she'll come and ask me these questions.
>> How old is she?
She is 20. No, 30.
I'm saying my 35. She's 36.
>> How old are you?
>> 35.
>> All right. So, is this one?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Is this their first marriage?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, so very Okay. So, how long they've
been married?
>> For a couple of year. Damn. I don't even
know. I think it's like
>> Damn, bro. Shoot, bro.
>> Couple years. I I don't know. No, it's
cuz when she got married to him, she
left and we don't know from there and
then finally she came around and
>> she disappeared. All right. Okay. Well,
anyway, we'll see if she comes back on
so I can answer her questions because
unless her questions are, you know, uh
it's best she asks me questions so I can
answer. Hopefully, she will. Now, what
is her husband?
>> I'm sorry.
>> What nationality is her husband?
>> Oh, he's from Morocco.
>> Uhhuh.
Yeah.
>> All right. It's how it is, guys. Muslims
can marry Christian women, can marry
Jewish women. I don't know what you're
going to do to
inoculate your children, right? And
>> it's never a good idea to marry outside
your faith, be it Muslim or Hindu. Never
good idea. I just got an email from
someone that's going to marry a Muslim,
and I said, "You're not supposed to."
I don't know why you guys want to learn
the hard way and marry outside of your
faith tradition and then kids come in
the picture and then there's disaster
and you guys really think your marriage
will last without Jesus Christ as a
foundation. There are Christians who are
married and they still struggle and up
in divorced
end up in a divorce. I don't get it.
I don't get you guys. Why would you
marry out of your tradition?